et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
parce qu'avec mme pascal mousset précis
président groupement du groupement
national et indépendant paris ile de
france
bonsoir parce qu'elle nous et merci
d'être avec nous à ses côtés à clé à
l'axel person cgt cheminots trappe
bonsoir vous merci également d'être là
premièrement messieurs première question
est ce que cette conférence de presse
cet après midi ça vous a permis d'y voir
plus clair
alex perd sont en tout cas en ce qui
concerne les puisque je suis travaillent
dans le secteur des transports
ça ne nous a pas permis de voir plus
clair dans comment rendre conciliables
les préconisations des autorités de
santé avec la réalité du transport de
masse en ile de france notamment en
matière de distanciation social puisque
c'est ça qui est préconise en premier
lieu avant le port du masque d'ailleurs
et aujourd'hui si le trafic va reprendre
à auteur d'à peu près 50% par exemple
sur les lignes où je travaille un peu
plus à l'air l'atp si l'ensemble des
salariés autour de travail lundi dans
des conditions normales il se sera
évidemment impossible de respecter des
règles de distanciation social déjà
qu'elles ne le sont pas quand on est un
service normal et notamment aux heures
de pointe donc sur ces questions là
évidemment il n'y a pas de réponse et on
risque d'aller au devant de quelques
surprises à compter de lundi vous votre
avis parce qu'elle a moussé vous vous
êtes senti un peu rassurés on reproche
souvent beaucoup de confusion ou
gouvernement est ce que c'est plus clair
pour vous pour l'instant pour le secteur
d'activité que je représente les cafés
les hôtels les restaurants c'est pas
plus claires puisque à ce jour on n'a
pas de date de réouverture on a un
conditionnel pour les zones vertes début
juin mais ça reste quand même un
conditionnel et on peut pas organiser la
reprise de notre activité avec des
peut-être il nous faut des certitudes
nos établissements sont prêts pour
adapté aux protocoles sanitaires on a
les fiches métiers qui sont prêtes
on a des collaborateurs qui ont envie et
qui ont besoin de travailler
l'avs le vrai point d'interrogation pour
notre secteur c'est à ce que la
clientèle sera au rendez vous avec des
établissements qui devront réduire leurs
capacités d'accueil drastiquement et
pour la région ile de france où les
régions très urbaine avec probablement
un déficit de clientèle touristique très
important donc on a on a beaucoup
d'inquiétudes sur ouvrir mais rouvrir
pour perdre beaucoup d'argent et
rouvrira pertes fait peur à beaucoup de
professionnels aujourd'hui quel serait
pour vous justement les solutions parce
qu'elles vont c'est nous en fait dans la
restauration et l'hôtellerie on a un
poids de charges fixes qui est assez
important aujourd'hui c'est vrai que
l'activité partielle de chômage partiel
nous permet de faire prendre par l'état
les salaires mais on a des charges de
loyer notamment dans les centres villes
qui sont très élevés et on a des charges
fixes permanente qui même lorsqu'elles
sont fermés continue à tourner donc
rouvrir en ayant 50 % dans le meilleur
des cas de notre chiffre d'affaires nous
conduira à accumuler des pertes et ses
pertes
on pourra pas les compensées et on
pourra pas les rattraper
donc aujourd'hui on demande aux pouvoirs
publics de réfléchir une façon de nous
accompagner notamment auprès des
propriétaires des bailleurs pour que
pendant trois trimestres
il accompagne les entreprises des
commerces les plus impactés en réduisant
les loyers pour nous accompagner à une
reprise d'activité
donc on les aidait confinement dès lundi
axel person pour vous c'est tout de même
une bonne nouvelle que l'économie
commence à reprendre d'une certaine
façon
donc évidemment on ne sous-estiment pas
l'un plaisant l'impact en cas ce
confinement sur l'activité économique et
donc les conséquences sociales qui
peuvent en découler
ça on en est bien conscient en revanche
les conditions sanitaires
doivent primer et en tout cas c'est les
préconisations qui sont données c'est
même pas pardon ce n'est même pas par
les cheminots les agents de la tp mais
bien les les préconisations des
autorités de santé sont de telle sorte à
ce que aujourd'hui en tout cas elles ne
sont pas compatibles avec des transports
qui fonctionne à leur pleine capacité
notamment en matière de distanciation
sociale auxquels j'ai parlé de la
distanciation sociale bientôt si une
bagarre qu'on mène actuellement dans
l'entreprise et même contre l'entreprise
je dis bien compte l'entreprise
pour obtenir des nettoyages bien plus
réguliers qu'ils le sont aujourd'hui
avec des produits adéquats ce qu'on
appelle des virucide que ce soit pour
les voyageurs dans les rames
aussi les espaces de travail des
cheminots qui d'ailleurs n'ont pas
vraiment cessé le travail selon l'uss
travailler moins pendant cette période
mais en particulier dans cette peur de
pandémie on met beaucoup d'accent sur
les questions d'hygiène et on constate
que l'entreprise est réticente du mois
accéder à nos revendications du mois à
la hauteur de nos revendications qui
sont en nettoyage des rames très
régulier c'est à dire à quasiment à
chaque terminus il égare bien puisque
deux sont aujourd'hui parce que j'ai
grandi en france qu'elle est qu'est ce
qui est prévu justement en termes
d'hygiène dans les rames de métro
notamment
alors pour le métro c'est les collègues
de la ratp moi je suis travail la sncf
dont je ne connais pas forcément comment
ça se décide à la ratp met à la sncf
dans les trains aujourd'hui l'entreprise
llc se dirige pour l'instant vers un
gros entre guillemets un grand nettoyage
des rames
une fois par 24 heures ok là viendrait
rajouter des opérations plus petites
deux fois par jour environ mais le gros
des toits y âge avec la désinfection de
l'ensemble de la ram le des toits de
toutes les surfaces se limitera une fois
par jour ce qui compte tenu des flux
très importants qui a notamment en ile
de france est largement insuffisant ça
c'est un des points d'achoppement qu'on
a avec la direction
en plus des videmment toute une
organisation du travail qui va consister
à être consiste à devoir pouvoir et
c'est assez des voyageurs dans les gares
et dans les trains et sa très clairement
que ce soit derrière lara tp ou à la
sncf ces entreprises là compte tenu des
suppressions d'effectifs que ces
dernières années sont incapables de
mettre en oeuvre c'est d'ailleurs pour
ça qu'elles ont écrit aux pouvoirs
publics en
quelles sont pas les moins de
l'effectuer donc elle demande le
concours de la force publique avec des
moyens coercitifs de répression avec les
polices à l'entrée des gars avec des
attestations des employeurs et des
officiers de police qui sont là pour
empêcher les gens d'accéder aux gars à
certaines heures s'ils n'ont pas eu
l'autorisation de leur employeur donc ça
ça risque de créer aussi des situations
de tension
donc c'est des sujets qui ont peut-être
été pas simple sur le tapis on espère
que ça va bien se passer le lundi parce
qu'on ne souhaite pas que ce soit
catastrophique dans les gares mais
plusieurs éléments laissent à penser que
ça risque d'être compliqué notamment
dans les lignes les plus fréquentées
parce que je le rappelle même que les
services est normal les transports d'île
de france sont déjà saturées donc il le
sera encore plus si les mesures fortes
sont pas prises pour réduire les afflux
de voyageurs et pour réduire le nombre
de personnes qui se déplacent dans les
gares et je termine dessus oui ça c'est
aussi une décision qui peut qui ne
dépend pas que des transporteurs publics
ça c'est une décision qui dépend de
l'ensemble du monde économique et il
faut des mesures coercitives donc il ya
quelques petits trucs qui ont été
esquissés comme la poursuite du
télétravail mais de très nombreux
salariés peut pas tes bras télétravail
et donc ils vont quand même retourner au
travail et ça risque de créer quelques
problèmes et donc on verra lundi mais ça
risque d'avoir ça risque de coincer
pascal mousset quel est justement votre
vue on a compris les craintes d'axel
personne entend régulièrement aussi des
syndicalistes chez les enseignants voilà
qu'il trouve que les conditions de
sécurité sanitaire ne sont pas réunies
pour poursuivre le travail
quelle est votre réaction à sa vous les
comprenez ou au contraire vous dites
aujourd'hui ça y est il faut y aller
coûte que coûte et faire redémarrer
l'économie de notre pays qui en a bien
besoin
notre pays est à rené allard est
confinée depuis le 15 mars
aucun pays aujourd'hui il ne peut se
contenter de cette situation
je pense qu'il faut que la vie reprenne
le dessus le travail en respectant des
protocoles sanitaires il va falloir que
chacun fasse un effort avec un effort
collectif et des changements importants
de comportements qui vont mettre un
certain temps à rentrer dans le dans le
monde
il faut que chacun fasse un effort mais
on ne peut pas aujourd'hui considérer
que rester confiné nous protège de tout
il faut qu'à un moment donné on apprenne
à vivre avec ce virus et qu'on partage
notre quotidien avec cette maladie en
essayant bien évidemment et en étant
rigoureux sur les protocoles sanitaires
c'est vrai que je comprends tout à fait
l'inquiétude pour les transports parce
que pour qui connaît les transports car
parisien on a du mal à se projeter sur
la distanciation sociale dans ces lieux
et je comprends ses préoccupations
toutefois il faut que la vie reprenne le
dessus et puis il faut penser aussi à la
casse sociale qui peut aussi entraîner
des drames humains tout aussi comparable
que locaux vides
il faut pas penser que la crise sociale
ne sera pas aussi terrible que la crise
sanitaire en tout cas on espère tout
mettre en oeuvre pour éviter ça et un
retour du chômage massif serait quand
même dramatique pour notre pays
axel personnes vous êtes d'accord quand
même avec ce diagnostic finalement une
crise économique d'ampleur ce qui
certainement nous pend au nez serait
peut-être potentiellement pire que cette
crise sanitaire ce sont des propos qui
vous chat ou vous aider à gérer d'une
certaine manière
non je le évidemment je ne suis pas de
on va pas rentrer dans un truc aussi
simples comme quoi le confinement
n'aurait aucune conséquence sociale même
sanitaire d'un point d'un certain point
de vue évidemment ça a des conséquences
graves d'autant plus que lorsqu'ils
concernent le patronat il est très clair
que dans beaucoup faire repartir la
machine économique pour faire repartir
les profits ça se vérifie y compris à la
sncf qui en plus une des entreprises qui
n'a pas arrêté son activité
même s'il a réduit fortement pendant
cette peur de confinement ce qu'on sait
c'est que beaucoup d'entreprises vont
chercher à faire payer cette crise aux
salariés de manière à faire repartir
leurs maris le profil la façon concrète
pas la can c'est pas trop dur ce seront
des plans de suppressions d'emplois des
licenciements et voire des baisses de
salaires ou l'augmentation du temps de
travail et donc une augmentation du
chômage qui peut en découler
et ça amènera évidemment une conflit
qualité sociale parce qu on est très
nombreux à ne pas se décider à ne pas se
laisser faire
donc je ne sous estime pas les
conséquences que
que ce mode de fonctionnement sur la
société c'est pas quelque chose qui peut
effectivement tenir pendant trois ans
quatre ans évidemment en revanche là où
on est actuellement dans la pandémie je
dis bien actuellement ça peut évoluer
d'ici quelques semaines
on est dans un des phases de la pandémie
et les autorités sanitaires ont
préconisé à ce stade de la pandémie
des mesures d'aidés sociales elles
disparaîtront un jour mais aujourd'hui
elles sont elles sont mises en
application et oui un autre devoir céder
respecter c'est aussi notre devoir
d'alerter sur le fait que en ce qui
concerne les transports
bon nombre d'entre elles ne peuvent pas
être respecté et donc là la question se
pose en effet parce qu'on passe outre
ou est ce qu'on met les mesures qu'on
les respecte et en posant la question
j'ai un peu répondu à ce stade là de la
pandémie va nous il nous semble
primordial que ces préconisations
sanitaires se respecter pascal mousset
les transports on l'aura compris à la
clé de la reprise économique également
l'école qui fait polémique certains
trouvent que là encore on des conflits
trop vite
est ce que c'est un argument vous
rejetez je pense que l'école il ya
l'italie a fait déjà fait un choix
inverse c'est un point de vue personnel
moi j'ai pas 2,2 g pas de qualification
où j'ai pas de compétences particulières
pour juger qui simplement que les
italiens ont décidé de reprendre l'école
en septembre et que pour reprendre deux
semaines trois semaines de classe avec
des classes très très très peu
fréquentées je pense que c'est une prise
de risque peut être importante mais
c'est un point de vue personnel qui
n'engage que moi
beaucoup de pays ont fait quand même le
choix de le régime du volontariat pour
l'école je comprends que ça ça répond à
une problématique sociale mais je pense
que c'est beaucoup de moyens mis en
oeuvre par l'état
beaucoup de risques pour des vacances
qui vont se profiler le 4 juillet et
scolaires et les lycéens est toute
petite partie des élèves qui vont
pouvoir être scolarisés
ça c'est un point de vue
vraiment beaucoup de gens partagent
autour de moi qu'ils osent pas annoncé
mais il ya des pays qui ont fait le
choix inverse qui ont préféré remettre
l'économie en route et qui ont dit les
enfants qu'ils ont du mal à respecter
les gestes barrières et son lait à la
maison jusqu'en septembre
merci en tout cas à tous les deux pascal
mousset axel person d'avoir été avec moi
en direct sur arte france